trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but sinks toilets
and shelves elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
for elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly in sinks and
[Music]
is trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements and bathrooms
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
like that this is just
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shot
[Music]
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
look at that
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that corporate
takeover censorship d-banking arrest
tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser and he's a
disgrace and he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace and he's a disgrace
look at that look at that
[Music]
mangoes my bad the mangos
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes manga aren't members like
three by seats
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bigger
[Music]
bring my mango back down
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't want me to be healthy and
highway robbery is what you're
[Music]
doing well welcome everybody it is under
unfortunate circumstances that we are
together today uh we knew it was coming
right i mean barring some change this
leaked months ago we knew this day was
coming we knew it would likely be a
friday we knew it would likely be in
june and today is a june and friday
uh june and friday it is in june and a
friday right and uh the supreme court
has overturned roe v wade eliminating
abortion as a right
federally
uh pushing this back to the states now
many people are writing to me saying sir
this is a good decision i love abortion
or i'm for abortion being legal i don't
know anyone who loves abortion uh but it
should be a state who decides
why
and why why why should it be something a
state decides should it be up to states
to decide whether triple bypass surgery
is legal i mean but it's arbitrary i
mean sure you can say i prefer a state
to decide
but
there's no real reason why it has to be
that way
and one of the things that's abundantly
clear
is that this won't stop here now i know
i know that there are many people saying
when i said a few months ago
this isn't the end you don't have a
major victory guys this is a 50-year
victory for them they've been pushing to
do this for 50 years
you don't get a victory you fought 50
years for and go
well i'm satisfied let's call it a day
and go uh shoot our guns and you know
uh but what i mean go to what do
conservatives do go to church and
you know
not teach uh
sex ed whatever um
you go further now that be and and
chakuseki here our resident radiologist
says thomas's statement shows this is
just the beginning they are prepared to
repeal all of the rights people fought
so desperately for what a shame they're
going to try more
i don't believe next year interracial
marriage will be banned i'm not not that
what i'm saying
but
they'll try to do a federal ban on
abortion right now it's there's no
federal right states can decide and a
hell of a lot of states are about to ban
abortion that's for damn sure but they
would say well let's ban abort let's
actually ban it at the federal level
what about gay marriage
what about um you know in texas they
want to get rid of the right to a public
education
for the children of undocumented
immigrants
just kids right i mean they didn't
choose to cross the border
all of these oh sorry hold on a second
guys
there's already people that have to get
banned i'm sorry
um
yeah we're just not tolerating the bs
okay guys so
just a lot a lot of ba i apologize uh to
to to interrupt uh to have to interrupt
um
so there's going to there will be more
attempts and the question is just how
far will it go and the answer is going
to be it depends who's on the court and
who determines who's on the court
presidents do so it depends who becomes
president of the united states uh not to
do another whole i told you so thing but
back in 2016 you had supposed leftists
going
the supreme court
that's not a good enough reason to
support hillary
at least donald trump has business
experience
they're the same they're both
globalish
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
right okay
if hillary had won
we would have roe v wade
it's
do whatever else you want you know
benghazi
seth rich
benghazi
the clinton global initiative
benghazi
hillary's emails
benghazi
private email sir i mean do what epstein
whatever if hillary were president in
2017 starting in january 2017 we would
have roe v wade benghazi
benghaz okay you guys get it
it's what it is
okay
um now
what next
what next well protester building of the
supreme court
protests i assume will be peaceful
no attempts are being made to breach the
barriers at this point in time
um
and we are going to watch this very
closely we are monitoring multiple feeds
and i am uh
excited to hear from you and see
what is on your mind as well we're
monitoring cnn as well jeffrey tubin
back from being fired for masturbating
on a zoom video uh on cnn is or
suspended i guess he is providing legal
analysis
so we have a lot a lot a lot of
different things going on
uh now one of the things i do want to
mention oh there's one other super chat
people are still trying to blame obama
yeah is that true i mean i haven't seen
that also my colleague john i have not
watched any of these
my colleague john assembled reactions to
this decision from marjory taylor green
josh hawley ted cruz gates paul gosar
trump jr liz cheney kevin mccarthy ben
shabibo uh dave rubin and michael
knowles
we'll we'll look at some of those
reactions and maybe we can guess what
what some of the some of them are in
advance now i do want to say one other
thing and this is this is uh just i'll
say more about this when things are more
calm
the the reason i was off the show this
week is not
because of paternity leave it is not
because of paternity leave i was
expecting to be on the show
horrible thing happened
uh my girlfriend fiance depending on
what day and who you ask no i'm kidding
um
she was rehospitalized after the baby
uh with
but she needed surgery with a very
serious condition a perforated ulcer
and i ended up just having to bail on
the entire week taking care of the baby
she's in the hospital it was not my
intention to be off
but it has been terrible
she's still in the hospital hopefully
we'll be out soon um we've got you know
people around for coverage today for the
baby
uh so really really really bad and just
you know
bad for every reason you can imagine um
a critical week for the baby
and uh an important week
from the standpoint of news although
that's of course secondary to
everybody's health and all these
different things so that's what's been
going on and my hope is to be back on
the show monday
um
the uh the the man with the greatest uh
um uh cranium in the business fair and
cousins
has said he can be on standby for monday
were i not able to host on that day
okay
who's looking after the baby now oh the
baby's right down there on the floor no
uh the baby's at home with family the
baby's fine
um
now let me address an interesting thing
a lot of people have been writing in
saying people write in with tears in
their eyes how they have tears when they
write i don't know but i just know they
write in with tears in their eyes
and they say sir
you have been a great pro-choice
advocate for as long as you've been
doing the show
now that you have a baby has your view
on abortion changed
has your view on abortion changed now
that you have a baby and many people
saying i used to be pro-choice i had a
baby and now
i am against choice that is a great
question what is the answer
has
my view
[Music]
on abortion
changed
since
i
had a baby the answer is it is not the
answer is it is not and in fact um
i
ne i would actually go even further
now that i've had the experience
of
seeing through a pregnancy
where an abortion
could be possible
at different points in time
i actually am even stronger in my
pro-choice
beliefs that's not a pro-abortion belief
it's not let's get people to have
abortions no no no
it's pro-choice and in fact you know
some some there's this idea you know
trump trump claims
he was pro-choice for 68 years and then
a few months before he ran for president
okay a few months before he ran for
president
he said
you know
i met a kid
and it was a great kid
and the mom said you know i thought
about having an abortion and i didn't
and trump was like wow imagine if this
great kid never existed now i'm against
abortion that's the explanation from
trump now i don't believe it even for a
second obama like not not even for a
second but
that's the story that that trump told
um
the more i think about it you know now
that i know the baby
um
what if circumstances were such that
an abortion would have been
discussed or chosen at the five-week
mark now that i know the baby and i know
that this is it would have been the
cells that led to this baby that would
have been aborted you know now nine
months ago
am i against that now no
i recognize that while this is now a
baby and a person that i know
at that point
it was something completely different
and it has no bearing whatsoever it
doesn't change my view at all that had
we
chosen or needed an abortion at that
time
it would not have been this person that
now exists and it's a choice that people
should be able to make i mean no so so i
think in fact the baby has reinforced my
pro-choice beliefs
for people who feel they need to or are
put in a position to make that choice
that's it i mean i don't know that i
need to say more about it um
but that is uh that is that other super
chats take it easy sir if you need more
time off we understand
wishing for a speedy recovery for your
fiance thank you
sir how do we fix this i think our only
chance is supreme court term limitations
well you know we could have prevented it
we could have prevented it just by
voting for shillary killery remember
people referring to her that way now
this is what we've got now this is what
we've got
um okay what happens in terms of access
to abortion in red states
people who can afford it listen guys
people who can afford it will continue
to get abortions
and and they'll be able to find them
either in state privately at off the
records clinics guys yeah this exists
or in other states poor people will
struggle
and they either
will be forced to carry to term babies
they are not necessarily equipped or or
predisposed to care for
or there will be dangerous so-called
home or back alley abortions
i mean that's that's what's going to
happen
uh
it's what it is and it's it's very sad
has to be a point where violence becomes
needed cannot sit idly by as nine people
turn the u.s into a cristo fascist state
against the will of the people that's
mikey
welcome back sir pakman i hope your
pickles are charged let me see if i've
got that still uncharged piccolos
trump's reaction on fox was to say this
wasn't his doing it was god's decision
how did he how did this with his picks
he did this with his picks can you
imagine i know
i know it's
ab absolutely
stunning stunning stunning stuff all
right let me thank a few people and then
we're going to go on to reactions i want
to say thank you to so many people
grabbing twitch prime subscriptions
merklist andy yamashiro sad shenanigans
physicist christina erroneous rich e
margot cabot raided roy holly garak
trisha north star rob starla ida tofu
staley explores
fury star
um ladson one uh no um wait a second
wait a second
no some of those people i said don't
even count so take two away and add the
freak and that puts us at um 11. i
really really appreciate that today's
coupon code guys
is resist the coupon codes lately really
requiring no explanation really
requiring no explanation i want to say
thank you to kevin ludecki for signing
up at joinpakman.com new member number
12 and also thanks to kevin combs for
gifting a membership at joinedpakman.com
that's number 13. if oh and sorry thanks
to juan for gifting a membership as well
if you would like to get a free
membership go to davidpakman.com
free membership put your info in we just
go in line we just go in line boom boom
boom boom boom okay let's get to some
reactions here let's start with
um
let's see what we've got uh
do you want to see
marjorie taylor green's reaction to the
ruling first i mean let's just kind of
go in order i don't know
um let's see what we've got here i
haven't seen these yet so we're all
watching these for the first time so
awesome oh my gosh
[Music]
i can't believe they just did it
man this woman is vile vile vile
[Music]
okay
so
she's she's giddy
let's check out oh sorry more of these
coming david congrats on the baby did
you see
magop governor charlie baker signed an
executive order protecting doctors
serving out of state patients i did not
see that but that's a great thing many
states may do it
have i ever interviewed ryan tyler cohen
it would be a great discussion between
the two of you i have not would be glad
to would be glad to
uh thanks to foisti
for the twitch prime subscription
i appreciate that
um mods in twitch and in youtube
please be on the alert there's a lot of
stuff going on right now and do not
hesitate to drop a ban hammer and we can
adjudicate them when the when the smoke
clears if you're in doubt just ban
because we're not going to uh it's just
not a day for that okay so modern
moderators you know what to do i'm
deputizing you let's go next to josh
hawley and see what josh hawley's
reaction is as the protests continue to
build in washington dc josh hawley says
doj needs to announce a zero tolerance
policy for violence right now oh
now there's a zero tolerance policy for
violence january 6th there was no zero
it was like oh well people are
frustrated because it was stolen now we
need no absolutely no tolerance for
violence
they've left radical leftists run wild
threatening the justices burning
pregnancy care centers no more by the
way how many how many family planning
clinics have been firebombed protests
are constitutionally protected but
violence is not doj must put a stop to
it immediately
uh okay so there's there's josh hawley's
big brain take
let's see what rafael edward cruz had to
say
the supreme court's decision in the
dobbs case reversing roe v wade is
nothing short of a massive victory for
life and it will save the lives of
millions of innocent babies it really
won't because banning abortion reduces
the number of legal abortions but people
determined to have an abortion have one
and sometimes it's a dangerous one he
also went on to say the decision
reverses one of the most egregious
departures from the cost constitution
untrue and legal precedent the u.s has
ever seen and one that has resulted in
the deaths of 63 million american
children they repeat that number it's
not a number i've ever seen confirmed
row was wrong the day it was decided and
it has been wrong every day since i
would actually say something different i
would argue if anything was wrong with
roe it's that it didn't go far enough to
enshrine abortion rights
if you search for the word abortion in
the constitution and the bill of rights
you won't find it what happens if you
search for ar15 uh raphael
interesting question all right this is
pretty pretty vomitous so we're gonna
get away from that for now that's that's
not very good
i want to say thank you to marty w marty
grabbing a subscription at
joinpakman.com you are number 16.
today's coupon code is resist
okay
you um it's very easy you go to my
website you choose monthly you choose
yearly i prefer yearly because it's just
the better deal okay coupon code field
beautiful coupon code is resist okay it
does wonders for a membership
absolute wonders absolute wonders
um
and that is uh i will thank everybody
who avails themselves of that thanks to
jen here kurakage and 10 flicks for the
twitch prime subscriptions your numbers
17 18 and 19. let's listen to
should we listen to any voicemails about
this actually i don't have any
voicemails about this if people start
leaving voicemails about this i will
play some of them i will play some of
them let's look at some other reactions
here
um
let's go next to matt gates what did
matt gates have to say about the supreme
court overturning roe v wade
i applaud the courage of the supreme oh
here's a statement okay
i applaud the courage of the supreme
court in standing up for our most
vulnerable in the face of violent
intimidation from leftist agitators and
the democratic party row and casey were
bad science and bad law
now their history the supreme court's
decision in roe v wade and planned
parenthood vkc were a stain on the
judiciary abortion is not deeply rooted
in our nation's history it is not found
in our common law all irrelevant the
constitution is clear i mean listen
gay marriage was not
deeply rooted in american history
because it wasn't legal
it's it's a it's a circular argument and
it's it's a bad one
the constitution is clear americans are
entitled to life
and should not be deprived of it without
due process of law
if a five-week old pregnancy gets due
process
it must also get citizenship right i
mean it must also be entitled to child
support right i mean how can they say
that only in this particular narrow
situation
he goes on to say every day the unborn
are denied this due process when their
skulls are crushed and they're ripped
from their mother's wombs limb by limb
until their hearts stop beating that
ends today states are now free to create
law that opposes the evil of abortion
and enshrines the unborns right to life
that's it's a very very sick person who
would write such a statement and a very
ignorant person i think i should say as
well
i think it's important to mention both
uh by the way he's under investigation
allegedly for child sex trafficking
which
are you being that great to young people
if that's an activity you're allegedly
involved in i mean i don't know you tell
me
you tell me what you're doing for
children if that's something you're
allegedly involved in allegedly
allegedly remember
why has there been so little coverage on
separation of church and state huge's
roe v wade is main school ruling will
long term be much more harmful okay i've
been away for a week so i i just can't
say anything about that right now
corwin
will there be violence if trump is
charged for january 6th um i don't know
i don't know remains to be seen
let's take a little bit of a listen to
cnn's coverage looking at state by state
states which are now preparing for an
influx of patients crossing state lines
to seek care so how severe are these new
laws missouri has eyes on targeting even
non-residents who might pass through and
conceive a child in their state and if
that person will get an abortion
elsewhere they could pursue them legally
oklahoma
passed a law just this year to ban
abortion from the moment of
fertilization texas and some other
states want abortion illegal after just
six weeks when many women may not even
know that they are pregnant correct
conservative lawmakers in several states
have embraced the idea that there should
be no exception for rape or incest and
almost all these laws carry stiff
penalties for medical professionals
caught providing abortion services
tens of thousands of dollars in fines
loss of their licenses and potentially
years in prison frederica
all right tom thank you so much
all right let's continue this discussion
right now i want to bring in senator amy
klobuchar she's a democrat from
minnesota and so that's the lay of the
land and it will be relevant very very
quickly
and very very soon quite frankly there
are actually states that already have
essentially total bans on abortion some
of them are really old they've sort of
been
they haven't been inactive they've been
superseded by roe v wade federally i
don't remember exactly which states
those are uh i'm not even gonna guess
because i just don't remember
there is a concern that particularly
brutal old anti-abortion laws now will
be activated as a result of this ruling
and um i need more time to investigate
that thanks to logo 22 for the twitch
prime subscription you're number 20
today i really very much appreciate that
um
thank you very much
and let me say thank you to a few other
really great people
uh jeremy laden just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 21 a few people gifted some
subscriptions that includes johnny
minogue our friend johnny and angelica
pilger gifting subscriptions numbers 22
and 23 and then thanks to kevin
nicholson for the website membership at
joinedpakman.com as well really very
much appreciate that let's continue our
tour of reactions to this ruling we will
go next to paul gozar paul gosar
let's see what he had to say take a look
as amazing and historic as today is
there is still so much more work to be
done to return this country to god
oh boy
oh boy
thank the lord for this day and thank
you president trump for making this
possible and we will ban men let's keep
our momentum and push over forward for
him
that doesn't sound to me like someone
who's satisfied ending it here
you tell me but when i read this i'm not
seeing
we got this done and we're satisfied and
that's it not the impression i'm getting
my friends not the impression i'm
getting
let's go next to the reaction from
donald trump jr donald trump jr weighing
in on the overturning
proud of my father for what he has
accomplished today funny trump doesn't
give a crap about junior but junior is
proud of his father proud of my father
for what he has accomplished today he
gave our movement three strong pro-life
supreme court justices and despite the
dems and the left-wing media doing
everything they could to stop their
confirmations especially with kavanaugh
he never wavered
he is correct
in that
because trump was president
roe v wade is gone that he is a hundred
and ten percent right about that
you can't deny him that reality that is
true
that is absolutely true
uh and we ex we were worried this is
exactly what would happen
super chats david sir if a federal ban
is enacted can blue states still thumb
their nose at the federal government as
they are with legalizing weed yes that's
a good question it comes down to
like remember under obama obama directed
federal law enforcement not to go into
states that have legalized cannabis even
though federally it's still illegal
you could have a president directing
federal law enforcement in the same way
but we can't count on that i mean sure
it could happen but that we can't count
on that
david surf republicans are concerned
about the most vulnerable is now the
time for democrats to demand loudly
child care health care family funding
etc yeah in fact
i tweeted about that
moments ago
and i said now that ro oh i spelled row
incorrectly oh my god that's so
humiliating now that roe v wade has been
overturned the right wing will show
their devotion to children by expanding
the child tax credit funding child care
and pre-k paid maternity and paternity
leave etc i can't wait for them to do it
obviously they're not going to
obviously they're not going to but
that's the whole that's the whole point
here that's the whole point if they
really care about children that much
maybe do something for children oh wait
there's an edit button now
is that true that there's been an edit
button added
no okay i heard it's coming i heard
there is going to be uh an edit button
coming
would be useful
would be useful
no uh supposedly it's in beta or alpha
okay um
rob with the 20 super chat
conservatives like to act like roe was
the first time abortion was legal in the
u.s ignoring the fact that it was legal
in practice for the first hundred years
of our nation's history before laws
started to appear 100 correct
100 correct
thank you to
um
[Music]
oh wow a lot of people signing up via
twitch thanks to norak
nug wrangler for 33 months months lurch
el cazo gifting 10 on what planet basic
days cipher 9 swill
and actual one all with twitch prime
subscriptions
that's 16 my friends putting us at 40 40
40.
um
very much appreciate that
super chat's continuing to come in
freakonomics suggested that post-90s
reduction in crime was largely the
result of legalized and accessible
abortion services do you see we will see
a big spike in crime 15 to 20 years from
now
it's so hard to say i mean
maybe those types of predictions so many
things are constantly
changing uh it's very tough to predict
is there any western country regressing
as much as the usa very sad to see from
a european perspective no i don't think
so the the us is unique in how quickly
it is uh going backwards
very very very well said
all right we've got a few voicemails
coming in about this
decision here's juan
hey david it's juan
my reaction to the roe v wade decision
is i think it's the wrong one right um
i don't know much about the topic but i
think that
18 weeks would have been a better number
you know midway point
um
i don't know man i think it's going to
be tough and
things do get much worse
absolutely
absolutely things are going to get worse
that's uh that's for damn sure here is
mark
hey david this is mark from chicago and
i just wanted to say you know
this is what conservatives wanted uh
you know they've been fighting for this
for 50 years
and where is their plan
to
working people and low-income parents
afford all these kids that they are now
being forced to have absolutely where is
the plan to
increase uh comp you know contraceptives
and sex education to prevent unwanted
pregnancy there's no plan their plan
which doesn't exist i mean their plan is
basically to live in a theocracy where
people have sex only in marriage
and it just doesn't make any dang sense
um it's just like obamacare being
repealed
they fight and fight for it and then
they have no plan correct i just wanted
to get that off my chest uh thank you
for the work you're doing and i hope
that uh
you and your entire family is uh doing
good
blessings to you thank you thank you
100 correct 100 correct
voicemails pouring in people's reaction
as the crowds continue to build
peacefully at the supreme court
hi david um well
i uh
be honest i'm not really surprised about
this nope
and i'm sure there's a lot of people
just wondering
well what now and it really sucks it
really stings but it looks seems to tell
people that really the only thing to do
now is just you know vote again vote
again
vote yeah and i want to mention that
there are people i saw in the chat who
are saying i we should never vote again
until this is fixed guys
it's not gonna get fixed if we stop
voting okay so please don't do that
that's not a good idea
that's not a good idea
uh i'm i'm unfortunately seeing
a little bit too much of that now
i'm exiting i'm not gonna vote for any
of these people until they fix this
it's gonna get worse then
okay
it's gonna it's gonna get worse
it's unfortunate
thanks to webtech pantaloons
sakirao
for the twitch prime subscriptions
also thanks to jr dubs really appreciate
that
today's coupon code at joinpakman.com is
resist
it is resist
i uh
i hate to say it
okay
but
one of the reasons that the right wins
is they're freaking relentless they're
relentless in a way
that sometimes we on the left or not
they will throw money at a problem for
literally 50 years
literally 50 years
okay
and they understand the importance you
got to keep the messaging going you got
to keep the pr going you got to keep the
local campaigns going you got to do it
all
um
and we have to make sure that we're
fighting fire with fire for as long as
fire is the name of the game we need
fire
okay
apples
aren't gonna beat fire i don't think
i guess it would they just get burned up
you throw an apple in a fire it burns
okay
so this is the time to vote this is not
the time not to vote
and
i do believe
although normally
gun safety
and abortion are not good voting issues
for democrats
i actually believe that in this
particular midterm
abortion and gun safety and the
disastrous actions of the american right
wing which most americans disagree with
may be good voting issues for democrats
okay
um do i think they will go after
same-sex marriage yes i'm not saying
they'll succeed but they're going to go
after it they're going to of course
they're going to go after it they're
vehemently opposed to it
vehemently even
so today's coupon code is resist
i ask you with peace and love grab a
membership on my website
this allows us to continue
sending correspondence around the
country having guest hosts
who get paid when i am
off and making us more robust we have
the coupon code resist i think the
normal rates are perfect quite frankly
but if you use the coupon code resist
you're really talking about a discount
that
there should be a house investigation
into these discounts let's put it that
way okay let's check in a little bit on
uh oh wait not this
uh oh hold on let's actually listen to
this i'm gonna step away from capitol
hill from supreme court restrictions on
women's health an overturning of roe v
wade and from congress now
a bipartisan effort to restrict
some gun rights so
put it all into context for us today no
i think you're exactly right a big big
day
30 years in the making in terms of in
some ways both of these decisions if you
think about the supreme court and the
sort of battle uh to overturn abortion
rights that has been about a three
decade uh push by conservatives and if
you think about what's happening with
gun rights it's been about 30 years
since all right i'm back uh i thought
there was a little problem but
everything's fine um okay so we're going
to continue watching this the protests
are remaining peaceful by every report
that i am getting
if people have other streams of the
protests that you would like me to pick
up i'm glad to do that
uh i'm just not necessarily aware of too
many others but um
we will we will continue monitoring but
every indication that these are uh
peaceful at this point in time if the
supreme super chats if the supreme court
bans contraception ivf could put women's
health at risk as birth control is used
to reduce the risk of ovarian cysts this
is very sad one of many things that is
sad
is mississippi's termination banned from
conception what does that mean for iuds
ecp etc all good questions that i don't
have an answer to right now
if this madness is happening why not
free birth control free tubal ligation
and free vasectomies
um
ask republicans i mean they're against
all those things
this is from the same supreme court
members who said you can't introduce new
exonerating evidence in a death sentence
if your lawyer failed to represent you
yeah they're they're disgusting
they're absolutely disgusting
disgusted with clarence thomas
concurring opinion people never stop
voting yeah this is not the time to stop
voting guys
not a good idea not a good idea okay one
other thing
um
what's this comment
any more trump rally coverage david i
mean there's this is we're covering this
this is what's going on there's no trump
rally right now what that i'm aware of
i don't know
um
one of the things about this issue of
abortion
is
i don't believe we will ever get to
agreement as to
when life begins you've got the people
who say
life begins
at conception and those who say life
begins sometime later
or is it the possibility of life and
then maybe even more importantly
when do the cells become a person
um
my view is that
this is actually a philosophical issue
and not a scientific issue i think when
you start with you know
a sperm and an egg
and you end nine to nine and a half
months later
with a baby that is definitely a person
uh i don't think there is necessarily
one answer
um
i i think it's the wrong way to even
approach the issue
it's
what about the rights of the mother
it's about medical privacy it's about so
many other things but i mean listen
imagine that 90
of the medical community and the planet
decided
at eight weeks nine days it's now
whatever it's now a person or whatever
just because there's 95 or 90 agreement
doesn't mean this exact same
disagreement goes away so it's not going
to be resolved in any kind of
satisfaction that way this is a moral
question a philosophical question and a
legal question that does not really
depend
on what is the change in a fetus from
week seven to week eight or whatever the
case may be
um
and i don't know that i mean it's sort
of it's i think you guys get it i don't
think there's more i can say about it i
think you understand uh sort of the
point that i'm trying to that i'm trying
to make here i want to say thanks to
crowbars forever cesaro beach ball
jeffahina
you know jeffahina sounds almost like
jeff ahana reminds me of cephei
cepha hyde yeah jeffahina
um with the twitch prime subscriptions i
appreciate that numbers 45 46 and 47.
massive dumps of memberships happening
on the website latisha lopez is a new
member
bevin molina is a new member and hillary
mcnierny all signing up at
joinpackman.com putting us at 55050
you can sign up on my website today with
the coupon code resist those memberships
are our primary source of funding let's
listen to
a few more of these voicemails as they
come in about what is happening today
uh
[Music]
let's listen
hi david i just i
wanted your opinion on
what you think about um
what what's next on the agenda for the
republicans
you know this was their ace in the hole
and now they've used it so where do they
go from here in the coming elections
what else do they have
who else are they going to go after this
is a fair question where i have said to
some degree republicans benefit from
having roe v wade to fight against
that's not going to be a problem for
them now they simply move the goal posts
and they say
now that we've gotten rid of roe v wade
we will work on two things as far as
abortion goes we will work on a federal
ban on abortion that would be the next
thing and they will work on banning
abortion in every state they'll go well
we've got to go to the blue states we've
got to go to california we've got to go
to new york we've got to go to
connecticut massachusetts rhode island
we have to start working on state level
bans there we there's there's still too
much of this they're going to be fine
guys they're going to still be able to
raise money don't worry about it don't
worry about it they've got plenty of
stuff that they can do
uh here's another one from jacob
hey david this is jacob from michigan
yes yeah with the
blue states possibly being protected
federally
for doctors
performing
abortions i mean
the way i see it is that they probably
won't want to put their medical license
on the line in the same way that good
samaritan laws
don't protect doctors if they save
someone's life with cpr or what have you
outside of a hospital
they can be held responsible for any
injuries
that the
person they saved could
could get opposed to if a random
civilian saves their life they can't be
sued and lose their license so
even
blue states i feel like could be under
the
under the hammer of everybody's going to
be under the hammer they they are coming
guys they are not you know the the i i
get the instinct okay of saying
this is such a massive defeat
this is such a massive defeat
that
we have the instinct to give up
and say i gotta exit
i've got to exit
but it would be the absolute wrong time
to do it because they're not going to
stop
they're not going to stop and
this should only renew our commitment
and dedication
drew says well we will likely be seeing
a decrease in women's mental health
physical health and worst potential
deaths because of this with the
pro-lifers taking no responsibility of
course
of course
this one we already did very good i want
to say a huge thank you to jade robbins
for signing up on my website marny hill
is a new member and christina ross is a
new member numbers 51 52 and 53.
um napa skip dog also signing up via
twitch prime i really appreciate that i
really appreciate that it's been a tough
month for the show we've had a lot of
guest hosts in i've been away first
because of my short paternity leave then
as i mentioned my girlfriend is back in
the hospital she had to have an
operation
uh for a perforated ulcer and it has
been crazy it has been crazy and i'm
glad to be here and sharing some time
with you guys now that we've got
a little bit of baby coverage and such
quite frankly tragic news tragic news
thanks to gopha for the twitch prime
subscription other super chats coming in
when roe v wade past the highly
conservative dems and gop of the time
we're against it people organized the
elites were forced to act don't be
fooled that it is the only solution
well said
sonia says after going through two
high-risk pregnancies i'm devastated by
this this ruling i live in pennsylvania
i'm very distraught over masteriano
potentially winning governorship as he
wants to ban outright wishing you and
your family all the best oh
if you combine this
with some of the people running for
governor doug mastriano in pennsylvania
being at the top of the list
we could see
a
mess even bigger
just backwards move for this country it
did it you know
i'm never hyperbolic right like many
times i go this election is not the most
election important the most important
election of our time like i'll give you
an example
in 2012
when the country was
very well uh recovered and continuing to
recover economically barack obama was
president romney challenged obama
um i voted for obama i disagreed with
mitt romney on social policy i disagreed
with mitt romney on fiscal policy but
like it's hard to argue that that was
likely to be
the election of our time if mitt romney
had won i mean basically the country
would have mostly
functioned similarly and rich people
would have paid a little bit less like
i'm not supporting romney okay don't
cancel me but the point is there it was
very hard to feel like this is the most
important election not as many people
paid elect attention to the results
barack obama won easily he was expected
to win it was like okay
um
the 2016 election was very different
why because of this
because many of us knew wait a second
you look at the age of justices you look
at all these different things
this could be one of the most important
elections
2020 was extraordinarily important
because it was after four disastrous
years of trump are they going to vote
for him again is he getting another four
and what that would mean
these i i don't believe it's hyperbolic
to say that these midterms
are the most important midterms i can
remember
and people in the chat let me know
i can't think of midterms that are
potentially as consequential as these
particularly because now with this roe v
wade repealed
lunatic trumpians running at the
government gubernatorial level
potentially the re-election of trump's
lunatics to the house
i believe these midterms are the most
important midterms at least that i've
covered i mean you know 2014 midterms uh
you know it's like yeah you know we
there was it was significant and there
was the
ebola fear-mongering from republicans uh
you
it just it's not like what's going on
right now okay it's just oops
so anyway that's that's my sense on
these midterms and it's only it's only
scaling up it's only scaling up
massive dumps of super chats are coming
in i don't know if you're familiar with
philosophy tube it's hosted by abby
thorne there's a thought-provoking
episode on abortion and ben shapiro i
don't recall shapiro's role i will check
it out david what can we actually do
from here as a person with a job and
responsibilities what can i do in my
life to make this better how can we
fight this uh we've got to vote we've
got to um
work for candidates doesn't mean you
have to donate right if you can donate
you donate but uh we have to oppose
dangerous candidacies doug mastriano
mehmet oz in pennsylvania are important
ones etc etc
i know this sounds self-serving but even
if it's not me we have to support a
media apparatus if you look at how the
right just shovels money at people like
ben shapiro the daily wire michael knows
knows charlie kirk mark levin all these
people
they do it because they go this is a
long term play
if this environment if this media
landscape is strong we get more wins
they get it they get it and you know
that i've said before
uh
uh hold on a second
i think i got a there's there's some
people some of these people getting
banned okay get the hell out of here
um
we've got to support a media apparatus
as well is the point
okay
was just announced the house passed
landmark gun legislation if there's any
good news today that would be it that is
good news
i haven't looked at it and we we will we
will uh absolutely be covering that will
the constitution survive this hypocrisy
abortion is not named so it's not a
right separation of church and state is
named but it's ignored what's the fix
here
that's a good question
that's a good question
do you feel a mass jury nullification
campaign should be started in concern of
the matter of roe v wade
i don't know how jury nullification
would would work in this particular case
my god david sir i've never been so sad
and scared in my life after 22 years
this is awful i'm afraid what will
follow many of us are
is it possible four of the supreme court
to be arrested on charges of perjury for
lying about how they they'd rule on roe
i don't oh so hold on was the decision
did it come was the decision different
than what was
oh they oh i see in their confirmation
hearings yeah no i don't think so i
don't think so no i wouldn't even be
thinking about that i wouldn't even be
thinking about that
i want to say thanks to jen here genesis
and cody kulp for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 58 a really
important day for website memberships
natalie cough thiel
is a new member and his new member
number 59. thank you natalie
nancy
mrazek i hope is correct
is new member number 60 today the coupon
code is resist i will thank everybody
who signs up louis berman is new member
number 61 today on my website
and also thanks to adam gingrich
who has gifted two more subscriptions
numbers 62 and 63. if you want a free
membership go to davidpakman.com free
membership and fill out that form it's
very very easy very easy
um okay let's take a tour of coverage
and see what is going on
[Music]
okay so that's going on there since this
ruling came down
well look the pro-life movement and you
see here in missouri it's a powerful
movement the right-to-life movement
look at these pro-lifers huh
look at these pro-lifers they've got
upper management written all over them
particularly this couple here hope they
talk to them well today is is a big day
and it's an important day and they're
saying that they are celebrating it
we've heard people honking um and
yelling sort of support here uh to the
pro-life crowd now just sort of down the
sidewalk and risk could come and i don't
mean to turn my back but we can try to
make our way through the crowd uh you
have pro-choice individuals who came out
here this morning they actually saw us
on tv and came out here it's a smaller
group they're laying here sort of
sitting here against the fence um and
we've been talking to them and they're
incredibly depressed about what has
happened there is a shock here
they look despondent well and when you
talk to women across this country um it
is worth reporting that there is a great
deal of fair of fear as well in that
community and certainly when i spoke to
representative cory bush she spoke to
that she spoke to the fear that is
amongst women because here in a state
like missouri which is a very
conservative state has a conservative
state government here there's a concern
amongst groups like planned parenthood
that birth control could be next birth
control is still legal in the state of
missouri we need to be clear about that
but there is a concern that there are
other laws other freedoms as planned
parenthood would say it uh that could be
coming under threat aaron
all right cal perry for us in missouri
today cal thank you okay so things not
looking particularly good in missouri
let's listen to cbs news lead in their
view to winning back the house and
possibly winning back control the senate
and i think now it's it's less certain
and so it's definitely worth watching
how republicans talk about this issue
because we've seen them before try to
strike a balance try to say look this is
the right thing i agree with this but
my state in some cases you hear
republicans say this my state has laws
on the books it's established i'm not
going to argue against that um so it'll
be really interesting to see you know
how republicans deal with this and i
think it'll be really well
they're going to have they're going to
have a field day that's for sure now we
are back at the supreme court here with
cnn size of the crowd here which has
grown substantially over the last
several hours uh this crowd was just a
couple dozen people when this opinion
came out now there are hundreds and
hundreds of people as you can see law
enforcement is gearing up there are more
officers now than we've seen throughout
the day
the big concern for law enforcement at
this point
based on what you see from the crowd is
not necessarily opposing protests
clashing because at this point
people who are in support of this
opinion have left so right now this is
just entirely people who are uh
disillusioned by this decision who are
calling the supreme court illegitimate
among other things at people who clearly
are protesting to try to preserve uh
some rights to so there's only
pro-choice people left
and the police are really gearing up i
don't know that i love the sound of that
guys you tell me an actor seeing this as
an opportunity to commit acts of
violence law enforcement throughout the
washington area has been concerned
about people who are utilizing this as
an opportunity to carry out acts of
domestic violent extremism that's what
they're planning for security throughout
the area ramping up capital police
ramping up staffing mpd wrapping up
staffing uh and that goes too for the
jurisdictions where the supreme court
justices live they've put for example in
one jurisdiction where supreme court
justices live they put their
civil disturbance unit which is
basically the riot cops on standby a lot
of concern within washington that this
opinion is going to draw out anger and
the big concern is violence back here at
the capitol right now but the other big
concerns gonna be right this attention
this anger this emotion could turn
toward the capital that's the other
thing all right
the emphasis right now and the focus
right there at the u.s supreme court
whitney wilde thank you so much that's
gonna do it for man federica whitfield
more breaking news after this
all right so that's what's going on
there and again if there are other if
there are people on the ground talking
to protesters i would love to pick up
those streams so let me know describe
them you i don't think you can put links
in the chat but if you describe to me
how to find them i will absolutely look
for those i want to say thank you to two
great people andrew wafter i hope that's
the right pronunciation and nathan
weatherly just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com and her new members 64
and 65. today's coupon code is resist
uh we're here
i would love for you to sign up at
joinpakman.com
right now with or without the coupon
code and i will thank you and we will
all rejoice uh this ruling is so
monumental says sin tsu i'm 75 and for
most of my life this flawed country was
moving in a positive direction i assumed
it was always going to continue that way
it has shaken me to my very soul to see
where we are now
well said sinsu
well said
how soon until we can see progress from
the left uh
gotta win some elections right
already happening that they have lgbtq
rights in the crosshairs okay i'm not
i'm not going to go to the uh thomas
calls for overturning precedence on
contraceptives yeah
not a surprise
hearing stuff like this makes me want to
move to canada i have a long-distance
relationship with someone there anyway
so it wouldn't even be just a decision
made from politics yeah i wouldn't blame
you
i wouldn't blame you at all
i wonder if the judges who decided to
overturn believe that they will be
blessed with a higher place in heaven
now very disgusting love the show david
thank you appreciate that
when will media call supreme court and
corrupt theocrats domestic terrorists
you know since their choices end up
killing people
never never that's not it's not on their
radar my friends not on their radar
uh okay let's take a look here
um let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails
about the news of today
hey david so i saw on instagram that you
made a tortilla a while back and you put
a fresno chili in it
um
i'm sorry but that is uh probably
unconstitutional
and uh you might just go to jail um in
spain and maybe a few other countries as
well yeah when i made my my spanish
style potato tortilla i am up front that
my inclusion of a thinly sliced fresno
chili
is not traditional it's whatever the
hell i want because it's my kitchen okay
that's all that's all that i meant
let's see what else we have here
on roe v wade
hi um this is jay from ohio
and
i wanted to talk about
roe vs wade uh being overturned yes
i think the thing that a lot of people
that aren't haven't been paying
attention to this don't understand is
that this
has to do not only with
uh abortion but also
the reasoning in zadov's decision has to
do
with
these unenumerated rights like rights
that are not explicitly in the
constitution
but they're going after not just row but
also
a burger fell
and then you know if obergefell and
lawrence are also gone
we're talking about we're talking about
a bunch of decisions that go all the way
up to brown versus board of education of
course it is naive you know a bunch of
people took issue they were like david
you're being hyperbolic you're being
hyperbolic about this is going to go
further of course it's going to go
further it it's obvious
thomas said it in the decision that
they're gonna that that they should be
looking to go further so you know i
don't have time i just don't have time
for it guys i do want to let you know
um
one of our viewers
put together
a a tailor put together this is this is
really funny
this is a hold on let me see if i can oh
damn hold on give me a second this is
really funny this is potentially an
element
that i could use during the pre-stream
uh songs wait what's going on here
there we go okay
let me put this up this is an album
cover
not anal bum cover of course as the uh
great skit includes this is
the essential david pakman as you can
see 32.99 that's expensive
it features bring my mangoes back down
which is great
and it does have a parental advisory as
you can see
so this is uh this is the album
find it in vinyl store it i would
recommend picking up a few pieces of
vinyl
30 oh it's 32 euro wow
now why does it say 2016 on it that i
don't know
so that's the essential david pakman we
will be offering that it almost would be
fun can it could i get vinyl pressed
it almost would be if i bet that that
would be interesting
imagine if i put some of our songs on an
actual piece of vinyl and offered it
it's got to be expensive
it's got to be really really expensive
it would take eight months to get it
pressed oh my god
that's horrifying all right sounds like
sounds like two more too much work ding
ding dong says as if we needed more
evidence that cops only back fascists we
are back to the dark ages and i fear for
our country's future many are afraid
how will these extreme changes help
republicans bring in new or more
republican voters that's an interesting
point i mean i think they would say we
are finally making progress against the
democratic machine join us now and we'll
go beyond just roe v wade
something like that would be my guess
um thanks to nasty cues and fungus
wungus for the twitch prime
subscriptions i also want to say thank
you to bev mister who just signed up at
joinpakman.com really appreciate that
thanks to celangel soul angel i'm not
sure how to pronounce it i've not seen
that name jacobs
new member number 69
and thanks to big d energy wow
quite a shot across the bow big d energy
is new member number 70 today the coupon
code is resist folks
today is a good day as ever to grab one
of those memberships let's continue
looking at super chats as they come in
oh hold on
i run an indie record label that focuses
on vinyl let's talk yeah please email
info
davidpakman.com i'd love to hear a
little bit about pieces of vinyl
all right
thank you for all you do david we
greatly appreciate your work wishing a
speedy recovery to your fiance and your
family best wishes would also like to
see a collab with brian tyler cohen
would love to do that
anytime
i'm seeing so many conservative
republican apologists on social media
acting outraged about roe either don't
know it's their fault or don't care
uh yeah there's no shortage of stupidity
that's for sure
mr pac dad sir what is your baby's view
on the socio-economic implications of
the supreme court overturning roe v wade
blessings to you and your family pac
baby
right now she's basically focused on
avoiding diaper rash so i don't know
that she's necessarily taken a big
position on any of the major political
issues she is pro-baby formula
regulation though that i can tell you
for sure
thoughts on impeachment for barrett
gorsuch and kavanaugh for lying to the
senate diana i i know i know what you're
saying i know what you're saying
but it's just it's not gonna happen
so i don't know that it's a good use of
uh of our time and resources i hate to
be so cynical
when have conservatives ever tried to
appeal to more voters their whole plan
revolves around reducing voter turnout
that's a fair point as well
that's a fair point as well
in ireland which was supposedly a
conservative country and was to the
early 1990s here we are voting by
referendus for same-sex marriage in 2015
abortion in 2018 i love my progressive
country
uh thank you andy thank you
funsom has just signed up via twitch
prime and his new number and new member
number 71. i appreciate that appreciate
that very much let's listen to a couple
of other voice actually let's see if
hold on let me take let me take a look
at who else is on the ground maybe
interviewing people
at some of these uh
at some of these protests let me check
my live now feed
nbc news we've got
a lot of these we already have going
let's see supreme court
protests
filter by live
um
let's take a look here
okay there are some protest feeds i
would like to see what the tone antenna
is
right
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so that's one protest let's see
there's actually a lot going on so this
will be useful oh this seems to be video
of the exact same thing
[Applause]
i think that um i think that this this
individual might be holding the
megaphone a little too close to the
mouth and it's distorting unfortunately
i do wish that protest chants had
slightly better
uh audio production just
i think you would get much more buy-in
if they did
but
you can't always have that okay this is
just the same feed it's just a
duplicated feed
so we'll keep an eye on that very
closely
what's with all the security can't
justices conceal carry under their robes
save the taxpayers some dollars and
practice what you preach right
if there's no right to medical privacy
then trans health care is in jeopardy
with the reasoning of the new ruling
especially in the climate of nearly
genocidal anti-trans rhetoric a major
concern
a major major concern
thank you to derrick wooldridge derek
just signed up at joinpackman.com
derek used the code resist
resist is such a simple word to spell
and it gives you such a great discount
so i appreciate that uh derek thank you
very much also thanks to blueberry babe
for the twitch prime subscription
over on twitch all right do you guys
want to take like a three minute break
from the roe v wade thing just to show
you how crazy the entire field of like
what's considered healthy food and diets
is i've been saving this for a while and
then because of all the hospital stuff
and everything i haven't gotten to it
you want to take like a four or five
minute break for something that's just
purely bonkers
is that okay or would it be
inappropriate we'll get back to this the
protests are only building
yes okay all right here we go let me set
this up for you okay so as many of you
know i've talked before many times
to me it seems as though
the
magic bullet of nutrition
doesn't really exist the concept of
superfoods well there's just there's
foods that are high in certain things
and maybe there are things that can be
good for some elements of health but the
superfood elements extreme diets
over focusing on any particular thing or
no carb or all carb or all meat early to
me it seems that the consensus is
uh
limit portion size eat mostly
unprocessed foods
um the mediterranean type diet is a is a
pretty good model you know uh
in terms of oils like olive oil avocado
oil are good fish is good and and try to
use
whole fat um
whole fat uh dairy and you know okay
whatever so so fine so let me give you
two extremes these are two different
tick tockers each convinced that what
they're doing is the healthiest thing
okay so first here's a guy called
carnivore md
this guy is like everything's bad just
eat like bull testicle
and whatever else okay so like here's a
typical meal for this guy all right
how i like to eat organs
my preferred way is to eat them raw
this is what i'm having for dinner
tonight i've got raw heart
raw testicle
raw liver and fresh raw bone marrow so
you do this
and do this
[Music]
so this guy's like this is all meat okay
and i'll give you another example of all
the things that he says are bad okay so
um
[Music]
oh hold on a second now now i've got
crazy stuff
going on
um
here's all the things that are bad uh
what was a good one okay here vegeta i
have a confession to make this morning i
ate a vegetable
not kale or broccoli i've never eaten
this garbage that's total [ __ ]
i ate a green banana which is basically
a vegetable you should never eat green
bananas fruit doesn't want to get eaten
when it's unripe that doesn't make any
sense as fruit ripens the amount of
defense chemicals in the fruit decrease
and the notion that resistance
so this guy's whole thing is like just
eat meat raw meat eat eggs
uh sometimes papaya vegetables are bad
for you you know the okay it's terrible
now here's this that's what this guy
says is the healthiest thing he says he
doesn't need to even like brush his
teeth with toothpaste he doesn't need
deodorant because he smells perfect
because he's eating meat meat meat okay
here's another one
this is high raw vegan
this is what these people eat okay check
this out give dinners as high raw vegans
coconut ceviche
sourdough avo toast with french style
cheese and shrooms
red pepper lentil bolognese
we use the leftover lentils to make
sweet potato lentil burgers with green
ranch
quinoa global with green goddess
broccoli okay and then sometimes they'll
have like
an entire bag of mangoes as a meal um
let's let's look at like another one of
these what we eat in a day is high raw
vegans we started this day with the
papaya then we broke open this 28 pound
watermelon can you imagine breakfast is
what looked like three pounds of papaya
and a 28 pound watermelon i eat about
half of it for lunch i was looking for
14 of the 28 pounds sorry
truck so ally made us a chocolate
protein frosty it had 20 thai bananas
we didn't 20 bananas guys like cooking
so we finally opened up our durian it
was so creamy and good
what we eat in a day
i'll give you one more of these um here
we go what we eating today is high raw
vegans we started by hydrating with the
whole cantaloupe followed by mandarins
and oranges i mean it's a plate of one
two three four five six seven eight
oranges for a meal it's kind of like
okay i don't i don't know guys for lunch
we share this thick blue dream nice
cream
then we found sweetheart lychees at the
market
for dinner we each had a plate of golden
potatoes with california avocado and
split two bunches of baby broccoli okay
to me
both of these extremes seem like sort of
like
is it considered i think does orthorexia
apply not only to exercise but also to
diet
it sort of seems like a like
pathological in some way like none of
this seems good none of this seems good
it seems that both of these are extremes
and i don't know how much of it is for
the content and whether they maybe go
and then just like hey you know i had a
little salmon with broccolini um
i don't know okay i don't know but it's
all kind of weird so to me it all seems
extreme it seems obsessive and uh etc
all right i am gonna refill my water
let's listen to what's happening and we
will be right back it's hard to get it's
hard to get pregnant without a man i
mean it's it's it's possible actually
but it's it's difficult and so it's a
it's a family issue it's a it's a man's
issue it's a woman's issue i mean it's a
comic issue it's an it's a huge economic
issue um but ellie uh about that story
decisis you know the respecting of the
president and about the slippery slope
argument i mean what how do you
interpret what justice alito said about
now a sort of everything's fair again
well there's three different
perspectives in this opinion that came
out today alison justice alito says look
even though these rights to abortion to
contraception to marriage to sexual
practices all spring from the same
source of the constitution the 14th
amendment we're only touching the
abortion issue today all those other
ones they're safe we're not going there
justice clarence thomas says oh we
should go there we should reconsider
those rights that we've established
regarding marriage and contraception and
sexual practices the dissent of course
says why should we trust
what you say justice alito because based
on the legal principle that you're
establishing here all those other rights
could well be in jeopardy as well they
should not be the descent argues but
they're in play now too so that's where
this is going to head in the future
we've got a split court but as joan and
gloria said this is a six to three
conservative court any way you cut it
and it's likely to remain in
conservative control for the next
several years at least
but joan chief justice roberts is a bit
of a wild card i mean maybe i'm
overstating that but the the way he
decided with this but not not thinking
that roe versus wade should be
overturned was that interesting or
unexpected to you yeah no it wasn't uh
it's interesting that you pointed out
allison but he had he had tipped his
hand during oral arguments back in
december in this case where
what he wanted was to uphold the
mississippi law the 15 15 week ban and
he had proposed that essentially during
oral arguments and also cautioned look
we don't need to confront roe v wade in
fact allison when the justices first
agreed to hear this case they said they
were only going to decide whether the
15-week ban should be upheld they
weren't going to decide the fate of roe
v wade i do want to make an announcement
i will be investing in vasectomy private
practices that specialize in vasectomies
that is going to be my next
my next tesla for everybody that's a
joke by the way i wouldn't even know how
to invest in that and they're probably
not even publicly traded companies but
i think you you sort of get the point
thank you to becky green for the twitch
prime subscription and i'm sorry for the
website membership and dana tompkins
number 74
and 75
also want to say thanks to pink and
blonde blueberry babe and harry for the
twitch prime subscriptions putting us at
78.
a 90 british pound super chat today's
top from jody
i'm glad to see you streaming today
david
thank you jody i can't tell you how much
i appreciate your support
40 months of youtube membership for jeff
rogers who says how can progressives or
even democrats at large ever win when
the deck is so stacked against them
gerrymandering electoral college etc
a great question one i've addressed
unfortunately too much on the show
because of how necessary it is to
address
uh thanks to thomas eight man and a
danish joint for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 80.
very much appreciate that
let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails from people about what's
going on today
hi dave is this a comment to your vegan
personal connor clinton
sorry i can't tolerate audio that's that
bad i just i'm just not gonna do it okay
sorry
hey david this is thunder from
california i was just uh
seeing how you feel about this
you know with all the white replacement
theory stuff going on you know the
whites are getting uh i guess
you know replaced
taking away the roe versus wade do you
believe that there'll be an increase in
let's say white nationalists
raping white women and forcing them to
have those children so that it can
increase their uh
white numbers oh my god i am
i am not prepared to comment on that
that is not something i've considered
deeply
and uh i am not going to uh i'm not
gonna weigh in on that at this time i'm
going to reserve judgment okay i'm going
to reserve judgment on that thank you
let's listen to a couple of others here
and see what we've got
uh
for something
sensible
if i can find it
hey david i hope uh you and your family
are doing okay um i'm watching your show
right now i turned it off in the
background
just for you but um
i just get this feeling with
abortions that
conservatives won this argument the day
they chose the term pro-life
and
it goes back to where you talk about a
lot about democratic messaging
and
same thing with the filibuster
the reason
that got shut down so fast is because
the republicans
just immediately were able to make it
sound like
you know like an abortion
to a conservative but um yeah i think it
really just shows we need way stronger
messaging and should have voted for
hillary obviously yep yeah listen this
is george lakoff has written extensively
about this if you're interested in that
check out some of george lakoff's
writings the the bottom line is and i
can make it very simple for you is the
following
when you have the better language for
even describing your side of the issue
even if it makes no damn sense you're
already at a structural advantage so the
abortion one is super simple right which
is pro-life pro-choice
isn't life good well being for life is
good it doesn't even matter what it
means it doesn't mean if it ignores
women's autonomy it doesn't matter if it
ignores health consideration just
doesn't matter
right pro-life i mean i don't know life
is good right so i'm pro-life how could
i be against life
a tax relief is another one that george
lakov writes about
which is
tax relief means taxes are a burden
lower taxes mean you have been relieved
so lower taxes are better
um
of course the left's position isn't
higher taxes are better the left's
position is if we're going to have a
society
where there's more than like 150 people
which is sort of like the largest group
of humans that can kind of
manage directly without infrastructure
about 150 people is what research shows
if you're going to have groups of more
than 150 people that want to organize
and do things together
it doesn't work to say each person has
their road and if you want you just pay
them when you use it or whatever you you
need some kind of infrastructure and in
order to pay for things you need taxes
and so what we want is
effective and reasonable taxation
to have okay
but tax relief dude it's my money
relieve my taxes take away the burden
they've won in a sense on the language
that's what the caller's talking about
that's what george lakoff has written
about and it's a very important issue
i'm glad it's
being brought up
other super chats we have a protester at
the very top of the new frederick
douglass bridge in dc the bridge has
been shut down
do we have video of that let's see
frederick douglass bridge protest
uh not finding anything live
yeah okay
north dakota has trigger laws in place
making abortion illegal there was one
abortion clinic in the state which was
beleaguered by christian fundamentalist
protesters weekly they will not stop
here
yeah
they will not
thanks to merrill mckee for signing up
on my website thanks to jeremiah
schnurley for signing up on my website
new members 81 and 82
it's a horrible day
and the coupon code resist
is the code that today
gets you an ungodly discount on my
website if you want to you can still use
the coupon code obama if i could spell
it correctly
uh it's an even bigger discount quite
frankly that's that's the truth obama
yeah
so feel free to use whichever whichever
you prefer
let's listen oh hold on one more super
chat conservatives realize that when the
supreme court takes rights away they
lose them too you may not agree with the
right but it isn't just liberals losing
out
fair
fair and well said
other voicemails
coming in
hey david this is casey from oklahoma
just wondering when you're gonna address
uh copying sam and having a child
after he did
i haven't heard your
reasoning for doing so and uh i think
you owe it to your listeners yep that's
true so first i stole sam cedar's panels
from his set
uh then i uh stole sam's judaism and
decided to be jewish too
and then now i decided to uh have a girl
as my firstborn just like sam did so i'm
basically just copying sam on everything
now one question would be when will sam
copy my subscriber numbers right that
way that that may be forthcoming and we
will see if and when sam is able to do
that
uh congrats papa pakman thank you david
sir we do not have a long-standing
tradition of women being along to vote
being allowed to vote that right exactly
this is exactly the point
earlier in the 20th century you could
have made that argument
listen women voting that's not an
enshrined right i mean listen we don't
even have a history of that
thanks to texas bear claw vaderette
symbolic gamer
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 85 85. let's listen to
what anna navarro is saying it could be
a state where people have some rights
and there's going to be since where
people don't have some rights there's
going to be a difference between people
who have women who have money
and the men who impregnate them when
they have money
women who don't have money this is not
getting rid of abortion this is getting
rid of safe abortions let's be real
about what this means alice you know
obviously anna there raised a lot of
questions but beyond the political
debate beyond the emotion and we will
ban men it's been about the practical
issues
who will support these hundreds of
thousands of unwanted
babies when they're supposed to be born
who will in these republican-led you
know more red states
will they expand the social safety net
who will pay the medical bills the
housing bills of these children how will
that work
look there are a lot of factors that
need to be ironed out as this moves
forward and is put back
at the state level where it belongs but
i can tell you uh having worked and
advocated in the pro-life community for
for many years this woman is one of the
most disgusting anti-choice activists
out there she's vile provide assistance
financial assistance for expectant
mothers
during before during and after they have
this their child whether they decide to
put it up for adoption or they want to
keep it themselves there are services in
place in the pro-life community that
will help in this situation but alex
hold on let me just let me just talk to
you about that there are something like
410 000 children in the foster care
system right now in the u.s so clearly
they're not all being adopted and some
of these babies will have obviously
physical disabilities how what i mean
what is the plan i don't know they're
not just all being taken care of
currently
well clearly they're already not all
being taken care of but they're like
let's just make more in the womb or
after the child is born is something
that needs to be discussed and
considered and obviously
taken stop the abortions now then
discuss and consider if and how to take
care of kids that are either unwanted or
that people are unable to afford great
strategy guys very much pro-life what a
beautiful strategy of life a message of
peace and harmony dear god
this is what happens when these people
are in power
louis berman says our jewish tradition
believes that the life of the pregnant
person is paramount and this ruling goes
against jewish law and tradition this is
a moment of mourning this is absolutely
true we covered this story on the bonus
show okay
typically in the united states religious
forces are against abortion the
evangelicals are against abortion the
catholics are generally against abortion
although they have moderated on it
against against against abortion and in
judaism
there is
uh paramount as louis is saying
that the life of the mother
must be preserved
if only in so far as if the mother dies
the mother
no longer can birth any other children
in the future and there's of course more
to it and if you don't no one person has
to care about any particular religious
teaching but the point here is
there is an argument to be made and in
florida they are suing that an abortion
ban
violates the religious freedom of jews
because the religious dictates are
you must preserve the life of the mother
and a flat out a flat out abortion ban
violates that religious concept
and i don't know where that lawsuit's
going to go
it's very different than what is mostly
the involvement of religion in the
united states with this issue of roe v
wade and abortion
but um
you know okay well said louis
i appreciate the message
thank you to therese pelkey who just
signed up on my website and scott tilley
who just signed up new members 86
and 87
also thank you to laura lawrence new
member number 88 oh not 888 88
uh very very much appreciate that all
right everybody my coverage for now ends
here i may stream again later and i i
hope hope hope to be back on the show
monday as i told you things have been
crazy this week my my girlfriend
unrelated to the pregnancy
and the delivery
had to be re-hospitalized for surgery
and all of a sudden
i've been doing the single dad thing all
of us and that believe me i will have
stories i will have stories but now
we're trying to get everybody
home and healthy and everything so i
hope to be back monday it may be for ron
kozins
but i will be back soon
okay
talk to everybody soon thank you for
joining me